hello everyone my name is reto Meier and
i'm ian ni-lewis today on the app clinic
will be reviewing the app clinic which
adding the microscope on ourselves and
taking a look at what we do why we do it
and where we're hoping to take this
runaway freight train of Awesomeness
will also be giving a shout out to some
of our favorite apps and mourning the
absence of the giant fake phone this is
the app clinic each week on the app
clinic in and I review a series of apps
in a particular category lately we've
been digging a little deeper
highlighting some of this technical
challenges involved for people trying to
build apps that fit into that category
and at the end of each episode we offer
our patients a set of prescriptions that
we believe will help them take their app
to the next level then the following
Tuesday in this sort of circle of
Awesomeness we have going Roman Nick and
Adam take another pass from a design
perspective they'll offer some insights
into how to make the apps more
consistent with the design aesthetic of
Android and even create some screen
mocks for apps that offer some practical
ideas for how to make your apps more
intuitive the idea behind both shows is
to take the conversations we on the
Android developer relations team have
every day and hold them in more of a
public forum and with less swear words
our team's mission is to help developers
create magical experiences we want to
make Android a better platform for users
and of course make a better platform for
our developers make it more successful
and to that end will be shifting our
focus to be a little more technical I
will be looking not just at the features
that the apps that we look at implement
but also how they're implemented we're
not just going to look at features
either we're going to be looking at
things like efficiency and how to make
your UI buttery smooth and best
practices in general that exist for apps
in whatever category we happen to be
reviewing each episode is going to have
a strong technical focus there'll be
plenty of code snippets that are going
to show you how to do the things that
we've been talking about all episode we
also wonder way to reward the app
developers the ones we love like tasks
hipmunk I am and camera fxpro these guys
our advice they implemented the
improvements that we talked about and
they took their apps to the next level
and so to that end we're creating the
app clinics pewa Android collection so
this is going to be a collection of apps
that Ian and I are going to handpick and
each of which we believe office Lee uses
a magical experience in some way now any
of the apps that we review on the App
clinic will be eligible for
consideration to include in this
collection so I think the big question
is how do you get your app nominating he
does indeed so if you have any questions
about the details that we're discussing
here let us know on the G+ event or on
YouTube or how are you watching the
event now and we'll try and get back to
them at the end of the show that's right
engineered dan is busy checking out the
ol that wasn't supposed to happen okay
that's right six that to the background
if you would Daniel there you go okay
uh-hmm so why don't I jump back and then
jump forward indeed perfect well not
quite as perfect that's not quite the
right one Daniel know there is a mom for
us behind interesting all right all
right okay now now play that thing and
it's gonna be awesome all right boom sad
yeah nominate excellent sorry guys it's
okay so we've created a trailer board on
which we take nominations for both the
categories you'd like us to review and
you can login to Google account so it's
it's pretty straightforward and then
anyone can add a comment to the
nominations card on the proposed
categories list now just in case you
didn't see that URL as it was flying by
the URL is bit ly / app clinic Trello
capital a capital C capital T so we're
going to go through and create new cards
for each nomination you can vote for
them and once a new category got has got
sufficient votes that we can make an
interesting show out of it we're going
to create a new list and exactly instead
then for each list so what you're going
to end up with is a 1 list which is all
categories which you vote on and
add your comments for the category black
and the movie kook go through and create
a new list for each of those categories
and that's what we're looking for
nominations for apps so that's so card
on each of those category lists is going
to be a place where you can comment and
say hey please nominate my app alright
so we can just see over here would be
the all right so this is where you're
going to nominate categories you want to
talk about that's right and then once
we've got a category that everybody
wants to talk about like Halloween ABS
our most successful category ever lutely
then you put cards in there and it works
a lot more like it works a lot like
moderator except there's no down votes
and you can see a lot more on one screen
exactly so this gives us a chance to see
you know what are the categories that
people really want us to look at and
gives you a chance to see ahead of time
what's coming so rather than just having
to keep track of what's happening next
week you can see that hey we're doing
we're doing social apps as well in a few
weeks time so I want to make sure that
my social app gets nominated and then
you can you know help get to get people
to vote them up and so on and so forth
so we're going to create the cards at
the moment you guys going to create
comments and votes and then a week
before each app clinic we're going to
hand select three or four of the apps
that we want to take a look at now will
generally try and select the apps with
the highest number of votes but we want
to increase the chance that the absolute
that we look at will make it into our
pure Android collection so we are going
to do a little bit of editorial work
we're going to look favorably on apps
that are self nominated as well as those
who that pass some of our most basic
tests now I'm actually going to break in
here and say that based on some of the
feedback we've gotten from our partners
we will probably move to an entirely
self nominated system so you will need
to make sure that the app developer is
involved with the app that you're
nominating if you're not the developer
yourself that's right in the reason why
we
want to do that is well for two reasons
and mainly it's because we want to work
with developers who are really
interested in hearing our feedback we're
going to be pretty candid I think anyone
who's watched the show before and knows
that you know it's always hopefully
constructive criticism but we want to
make sure that if we're putting this
advice out there that the people who are
giving it to want to hear it and want to
be able to take advantage of what we're
telling it so speaking of tests let's
talk about how you go from an athlete
patient to a pure Android member we'll
start by putting each app through our
basic QA checklist which you may
recognize as the recently finished
Android corps app quality guidelines now
this is the low bar it basically just
demonstrates that your app runs and
doesn't crash and follows the the most
basic set of quality guidelines we can
think of so they we'd like to think that
you've already run your apps through
this cheque la check list before you
publish it on on Google Play let alone
submit it to us to have a look at so we
might use this as a way to filter out
some of the apps which aren't quite
ready for us to review you right now
after we do the the basic checklist
we're going to look at how your app runs
on tablet devices you know that this is
the year of the Android tablet not to be
confused with 10 years from now which is
so you're of the Linux desktop that's
right waiting for that that's right now
we're going to we're going to use the
tablet app quality guidelines as a guide
there and it's important that your app
not only work but it works well on all
devices so that means phones and tablet
so we'll be giving it a good going-over
on a phone on a 7 inch and a 10 inch
tablet before we consider it for part of
the pure Android collection are we gonna
do 12 inch 15 inch tablets we may we may
do it yeah we'll play it by you all
right now the last deal breaker is going
to be your feature graphic every app in
a category needs to have a feature
graphic in order to be included and
that's not just us being difficult it's
actually technical requirement so if
you're nominating your app for a view
and you want it to be considered for
entry to the pure Android collection you
just you need to have a feature graphic
in fact we're actually gonna take a look
at all of your assets feature graphics
icons and even your app descriptions
yeah and then Nick
and Roman and Adam will take we'll go
through each of the apps through the
prism of the Android design guide on
Tuesdays Android design in action
offering some suggestions for how to
improve your user experience of each of
the apps from a design perspective as
well as the category in general and the
usual user experience tips that these
guys have it to provide now remember
we're not expecting every app that we
look out to be perfect from the first
time we see it no the point of the app
clinic isn't defined the very best most
popular app in each category there are
other featured lists that do exactly
that we're developer advocates so it
makes it a good day for us is when we
find a way to help a developer take
they're good at and make it a better up
so don't worry if we review your app and
give you a bunch of constructive
criticism the very fact that we reviewed
your app means that it has some
interesting functionality that we think
what needs to be represented on Google
Play giving you constructive criticism
gives you an opportunity to take that
great functionality and turn it into a
wonderful app absolutely out what we're
really hoping to create is a knowledge
base of information that helps not just
the apps that we review but everyone who
watches and all the other Android app
developers to create really magical
experiences for their users which is
awesome because you are a magician and
you will be showing us how to make
things magic exactly and I may get into
a little bit of trouble from the
magician's trade union for giving away
some of the secrets but ultimately I
think it's worth it you know what what's
really magic I can wave my hands and
make make the office turn green oh I
can't though oh yeah you can okay
whatever well the one time we do want
the lights to screw up I'll make it good
we'd turn oh well good job Dan
engineered an okay so what we're really
trying to uh you want to hear back from
you we want to hear back from the
developers who zaps we're reviewing and
we want to hear back throughout the
entire cycle of going through and
applying the ideas we've had rejecting
some accepting others going through
technical challenges that entire process
of improving the apps would really like
to work with you closely and
fully record that process silly I mean a
lot of what we're doing here it's really
easy for us to stand here flick through
your app and tell you what you should be
doing differently but we're really
interested to hear what happens when you
try and take that advice and it's a case
of hey we thought about that and we
chose not to do it for a reason or we
took your advice we tried to do it and
we ran into these roadblocks that's
really important and useful information
so we're going to continue to regularly
broadcast develop a strike back and
that's your opportunity for the
developers whose apps that we've
reviewed to respond to us now rather
than following up the week after the app
clinic we're asking us or we're asking
you to let us know when you've got
something you'd like to share we're
really looking forward to hearing some
real war stories around the
implementation suggestions or the
implementation of the suggestions that
we've given you so both tales of success
like yeah we tried to do this thing and
now our list views of buttery smooth or
frustration like yeah we tried to
implement this this skeuomorphic design
alternative and it really didn't work
out and I users you know Rab testing and
our beta beta releases just sure that it
wasn't working so we're going to get
both ends what are we getting right what
are we getting wrong what are you
finding easy what are you find it
difficult so we can then feed that back
into our system as well and try come up
with ways to make the things that we
think of good easier for you guys to do
so that is hopefully going to save other
developers pain as they try and improve
their apps now once you've been reviewed
let us know whenever you think you're
one step closer to pure Android and
we'll take another look if we notice
something that's particularly cool or
particularly challenging we'll invite
you to developers strike back to talk
about what you've done and then once
your app is pure Android magic will
induct you into the pure Android
collection which will hopefully offer
you some extra downloads but more
importantly will give you an opportunity
to break to France course we're really
looking forward to the new format and we
hope that it helps provide some
recognition and motivation and hopefully
some income to the developers who are
brave enough to offer up your apps for
public scrutiny so with that I think
we're going to open it up to questions
from the internet so Sarah dear dad is
there any any questions from any of the
people who may have tuned in to let us
know what they need to do no but we do
have one one comment it says you guys
are incredibly lucky to be
employed the way you are and your job is
basically just criticize someone else's
work and they do all the work so good
for you guys there is an aspect to that
I want I won't lie but I mean in truth
it's not really about the criticism what
we're really trying to do is find out
more ways to be able to help you guys to
build great apps we're really trying to
make it easier for developers to build
the sorts of apps that we want to use
and the people want to use yeah you got
to remember that this is only a small
part of our jobs most of the time what
we're doing is writing all the
documentation on developer android com
creating the tutorials writing sample
code and writing things like the app
compatibility library absolutely so if
there are specific technical issues or
problems with the operating system or
with a framework that that are
preventing you from creating a great app
it's our job to help you some amount
those obstacles and whether that's by
creating a compatibility library by
writing a better tutorial by documenting
things differently or by going in and
fixing issues with the operating system
itself that's our job so we want to hear
from you so that we can do our job
better absolutely I mean that's a key
part of what we do it's like you know we
do stand here and in this show in
particular it's all about trying to help
developers build something better and in
doing so criticizing those who haven't
done the best that they can do but it
really the reverse part of our job is
taking all of that feedback from you
guys and that's why we really mean it
when you say you know we tried to do
what you said and we couldn't for
whatever reason we want to hear that not
just because it changes the message that
we can tell other people but so that we
can go back to the framework team so
that we can go back to our sample code
to the support library to the developer
tools and figure out ways to really make
that process easier for you guys so we
take that the notion of like at Google a
lot of companies would call the role
that we have take advanced and a Google
we call ourselves advocates and the
reason for that is because we really
care about having that reverse lens we
want to be able to take the suggestions
and the experiences that you guys have
and feed it back into the system to try
and improve that yeah I mean we sit
right in the middle of the framework
team on one side we've got the video and
media guys and graphics then we've got
all the
the windowing and support and USB and
and just basically in a horseshoe around
us and you will often find us going
around to those people to either ask
what it is the antenna so you know I'll
say you know Diane hack born for
instance there's this perfectly
legitimate request that I just got from
a developer and I really think that we
can't satisfy it correctly and then you
know because I an is smarter than me
she'll usually say well actually they've
they've sort of approached it wrong
here's the way the system is supposed to
work and here's way that makes more
sense you know or you know one of the
video guys will be like wow you know we
don't have that that feature right now
so here's what you have to do to work
around it or hears you know when we
think we're going to have it can you
collect some more informations can you
find more partners that need this you
know we have these interactions all the
time so yes our job is incredibly
awesome yes that is there is no there's
no debate about that aspect and and yes
we do criticize lots and lots of things
all the time which i think if you've
ever worked in or near a developer
relations team you will know is pretty
much par for the course yeah but if you
like to complain it's a pretty good
career path to take the criticism isn't
part of our job it's usually what we
just do over over beers on Friday night
the real task that's this before us and
then most difficult and complicated but
satisfying thing that we need to do is
to make this a better platform for
developers and part of that is making it
a better platform and part of that is
making sure that you as developers know
how good the platform is already exactly
i'm going to think that's what has
driven a lot of what we're doing on the
App clinic is a frustration and saying
look here's an app that is really really
good but it's not as successful as it
could be and some of the reasons for
that is that the developer just may not
know what they could be taking advantage
of and so that's really what we're
talking about with the new direction to
the App clinic is to try and drive it
more and more into that technical ground
so that where we're not really going to
be that focused on you know a feature by
feature breakdown in comparison between
the apps we're really looking at okay so
for all of the apps in the category here
are the key things that you need to know
and for these specific apps here are a
bunch of new things that you can do to
make this app even more compelling to
increase engagement increase downloads
and hopefully lead to increase
monetization however you choose to
monetize your apps the other thing that
that we really need to bring up is what
motivates us to change the show in this
way and it's because it is very easy for
us to point out you know oh look there's
a menu button of shame here's an action
bar that doesn't work the way you think
I mean that that stuff is incredibly
trivial but we realized that most of the
problems that people are having if they
are truly interested in making great
Android apps don't have anything to do
with that they've already read the
design guidelines they've already sort
of decided what they're going to follow
and what they're going to change but
they may be doing something like we like
we brought up last week where you're
requiring the user to type in a long
username and password in order to even
use the app which as we know reduces
engagement so we want to make sure that
we're showing the best practices for
things like that and also trying to
solve common problems that affect many
different applications exactly i think
another important part of what we're
trying to do particularly with this show
but i think across developer relations
the platform the android platform
iterates pretty frequently so there's a
lot of new features that come out at a
rate of seems like at least every six
months these days and so we know that
obviously it's our job to know what all
of those things are and so we keep track
of that it always seems like all of this
stuff is so obvious we've seen it for so
long why isn't everyone doing it
unsurprisingly not every developer
spends every minute of their day hitting
f5 refreshing their developer android
com site to find out what new AP
although some of you do and we know who
you are and thank you when those page
views of paying our bills exactly so a
big part of this is third for apps like
one of the apps that we looked at just
last week grocery IQ great app wonderful
design a lot of thought and effort went
into it but i think the developers of
that app just haven't necessarily been
able to keep track of all of the fancy
new features that are available which
can make that up even more compelling
even more exciting and so a big part i
think of what we're going to be telling
our
bella purrs and our audience is some of
the cool new functions the new features
the new api is that you can use to help
improve your apps make them even better
for you know all the newest Android
device so innocent they're kind of a
particularly important audience you know
there may not be the biggest number but
they are people who tend to drive
engagement and more importantly the ones
which tend to set trends amongst their
friends so if you get those early
adopters and get them to love your app
they're the ones who are going to tell
their friends their family about this
cool new app that you should they should
be using so there's an opportunity there
and hopefully that's something that we
can help you guys drive towards exactly
the other thing to keep in mind is that
last year when we started talking about
action bars and buttons of shame it was
all sort of new and if you were
approaching your app from a market share
position looking at devices and how iOS
versions and trying to hit the largest
sweet spot it probably wasn't a
particularly compelling story that has
pretty much changed the tide has turned
and we're now going from the old
gingerbread world which was heavily
focused on on varying UI patterns per
device UI / manufacturer you I lots of
different buttons lots of different
assets that you either had to use or
ignore at your peril now we're in the
ICS and jelly bean world where things
are considerably better designed from
the OS standpoint there are design
patterns that affect every device on the
market and the OS itself has gotten
significantly faster so any poorly
performing application or poorly
designed application sticks out like a
sore thumb yeah and that's something you
you never want to stick out for the
wrong reasons you want to be an app
which sticks out for being the shiniest
the fanciest the newest not the one
which looks like it was designed several
years ago and so that's a big part
particularly of what the Android design
an action team are going to be looking
at on Tuesdays is really trying to
figure out ways that apps particularly
apps which have a unique look and feel
can maintain that uniqueness
while still being consistent with the
platform overall and I think that's a
really important part of what we're all
trying to focus on is we don't want to
create homogeneity across all apps i
don't want everything to look the same
and act the same but we do want to make
it easy for users to understand how to
explore the features how to get started
so hopefully what we'll end up with in
this collection what we really in visit
you something that we can point to to
say hey if you want to build something
awesome on android that users are going
to love that fits into the platform
while still having its own uniqueness
and rich features check out these apps
and so that's really the the guiding
principle behind the apps that we're
going to choose not necessarily the one
which has the most downloads but the one
which we think sort of highlights what
android what's possible and android so
that you know views and developers alike
have something to aim for in terms of
you know what they should be aspiring
towards now that's a very long answer to
a comment that wasn't actually a
question very true I if I we going to be
to dig but we'll take a dig and turn it
into a 15-minute answer right yeah and
next week we're going to answer all our
YouTube comments from last week oh
you're kidding did we get any other
questions or any actual questions or
comments which we can similarly comment
on on G+ or on YouTube yeah so we've got
a lot of thank yous in the comments when
youtube today you know just for having
these live shows every week people
really appreciate the fact that they can
interact with you guys for even a short
amount of time and they know that you're
you're actually really busy and you know
that day earlier about not really doing
anything but criticizing other people's
work you know it's just one one-off
comment well you know I mean that's the
thing it's like it would be pretty
ironic if if we did spend any amount of
time criticizing other apps and weren't
able to take criticism ourselves so we
definitely want to hear that feedback
you know things like you know a good
example we heard a lot of people talking
about the fact that they really love the
action bar and I wanted to use a pattern
like that in their app but that it was
non-trivial to implement and if we're
going to complain about people not doing
it the right way shouldn't we make it
easier and so that's the sort of thing
which leads back into you know teams
within walk within our team in fact
going around trying to build some of
those things put them in the support
library for you guys two years although
oddly enough in this weird coins
yesterday we got two separate emails
asking why why did the menu go away in
API level 10 or 11 yeah yeah and it's
interesting I think a lot of the times
what we see is this this clash almost
where we have an internal team deciding
that this is the way that the platform
is going to go and external developers
going well actually I kind of disagree
and sometimes it can go both ways we saw
with the with the dashboard pattern with
something which we were promoting back
in the gingerbread days it didn't really
work particularly once you put it onto a
tablet at st. well actually this isn't
so great so that back and forth is is a
big part of what ends up driving future
directions for things like Android
design well and you'll see to that the
Android designers have taken feedback
from elsewhere for instance there is now
a design pattern for the drawer pattern
absolute where there wasn't before hmm
the nice thing is once it's codified as
a design standard you know basically
they didn't create the drawer pattern
but they did look at the way everybody
had implemented it and tried to pick the
particular type of implementation that
fit the best with the platform and with
user friendliness and usability in
general and so now there's a pattern and
it's not the way that for instance the
original google+ app did it it's closer
the way the original YouTube because
it's pretty pretty close to a YouTube
show coupe us app is now updated
actually and yeah it's actually a little
more usable so that sort of thing is
actually extremely valuable to us when
we hear that there's a particular you I
pattern that's either absent or getting
in the way of making your app great now
obviously if you're the type of designer
and I know that that that this exists
you know if your boss is carrying some
other type of phone and they come in
they say we hate your design because it
doesn't look right and you say no it's a
perfect Android design and they're like
well it doesn't look like my smartphone
we know that can be tough yeah but in
general if you're trying to make an
Android design and it doesn't work for
whatever reason we want to hear about it
because we want to fix as many of those
as we can and anyone who's willing to
work with us on a continual basis and
implement our suggestions and make our
design better is very likely
to get some help from us absolutely I
think that's an important part of what
we're trying to offer here and then and
really the justification for a while
we've you know sort of rebooted our app
clinic series today is because we want
to make it clear that the apps that we
that we do talk about we're not just
putting you up there like a pinata to
take hits and then move on we really
want to hear back from you we want to
know what are you doing what worked what
didn't work what was harder than it
should have been you know we we really
interested to know if we say oh we think
you should just change this button over
here slightly and you're like yeah man
that took like two days of work we had
to hire a designer for half a day we
need to know you know it's that's the
sort of thing which we can really do
actions on so it needs to be a two-way
street here this is an opportunity that
I think some of you guys will find quite
useful and certainly I would have back
in the days when I was writing code
every day instead of you know doing
developer relations is hearing that
advice for being able to really speak to
the people who are providing it and get
that input as to how well how can I do
this and these are the struggles that
I've had and so this is us putting
ourselves out there and giving you guys
the opportunity to you know do have that
back and forth let us know what's
working what's not working and ask us
questions and that's really when we're
talking about taking technical deep
diets that's what we want to spend the
time on these shows doing is showing you
exactly how to implement difficult
things and creating as much content
around that as we can and in general or
what we're going to try and do is keep
the show to half an hour but have some
question time afterwards so we'll still
scheduled an hour from our day and we
may actually pre-record some of the
segments of the show only those which
don't affect the outcome exactly but we
will always be here live for questions I
at the appointed time just go ahead and
type them into YouTube we type in a G+
looks like youtubes probably the the
preferred scenario right now because
that's what Dan's got up on screen I'm
going to try and do a lot better as well
when it comes to responding to this
stuff in real time oh there you go dance
got that one's good he's gonna go a lot
them he's got his under control is on
top of things well let us know so Dan is
there anything else that stands out as a
question yeah one of our
usual viewers funny goat wants to know
where the pure Android collection and we
posted 20 so we'll have more details in
exactly where you can find all of this
stuff once we've got a few apps to put
in there so we're gonna we're going to
take a quick look back across some of
the apps that we review review we've
reviewed that will happen to my tongue
there over the last few weeks I know
camera zoom FX have just released and
exciting new update which does a lot of
the things which the Android design in
action team suggested so we're going to
probably this week spend a bit of time
and check out if any of the apps which
we reviewed are ready to become part of
the collection and as soon as we have a
couple of guys in there then we'll tell
you guys all about where you can find it
and we'll definitely be making a big
deal of it then so right now it's a it's
a call for nominations basically so if
you've had your app reviewed by us and
you've already made also updates please
let us know so we can check it out and
then anyone who we know who we review in
the future same thing as soon as you're
ready for us to take a look and give it
the the app clinic stamp of approval
we'll go through that process and amble
that you will know in general the way
collections work is we can link to them
from from our website at any time I and
they have the ability to be featured on
google play but they're almost never
featured for very long time so we can't
guarantee that the collection will
appear on the google play store at any
particular time because that's a
merchandising team decision but we can
tell you that will always be available
for you developers to take a look at
exactly so we'll be pointing at it and
they'll always be a link that you can
point at two and i should point out as
well the thing about these